MERRICK GARLAND WAS PRESSED ON
THIS, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
THE UNITED STATES YESTERDAY.
LET'S PLAYING A LITTLE BIT OF
HOW HE RESPONDED TO WHETHER OR
NOT -- OR WHERE HE IS ON THE
POSSIBILITY OF CHARGING DONALD
TRUMP.
>> NO PERSON IS ABOVE THE LAW IN
THIS COUNTRY.
NOTHING STOPS US --
>> EVEN A FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW TO -- MAYBE
SAY THAT AGAIN.
NO PERSON IS ABOVE THE LAW IN
THIS COUNTRY.
I CAN'T SAY IT ANY MORE CLEARLY
THAN THAT.
>> THAT'S A REALLY NOTABLE SOUND
BITE FROM HIM SAYING -- THE
REPORTER IS LIKE TRYING TO
FOLLOW UP AND HE'S LIKE, NO, NO,
NO, JUST LET ME GET THIS OUT AND
SAY THIS AND MAKE THIS CLEAR.
I AM ASSUMING HE WILL BE
WATCHING CLOSELY TONIGHT.
>> IT'S ALSO WORTH REMEMBERING
HOW THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
WORKS.
MERRICK GARLAND IS NOT GOING TO
WAKE UP FIVE MONTHS FROM NOW OR
SIX MONTHS FROM NOW AND SAY, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO INDICT
DONALD TRUMP.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A PROCESS.
THERE WILL BE LINE
INVESTIGATORS, THERE WILL
BELIEVE THE FBI INVESTIGATING
DONALD TRUMP, THERE WILL BE A
REVIEW PROCESS OF PEOPLE
DECIDING WHETHER OR NOT AN
INDICTMENT IS WARRANTED AND THEN
IT WILL MOVE UP THE CHAIN TO
MERRICK GARLAND.
HE IS NOT GOING TO MAKE THIS
DECISION IN A VACUUM.
THE QUESTION THAT SO MANY PEOPLE
HAVE IS HOW AGGRESSIVELY ARE
THEY CONDUCTING THE
INVESTIGATION NOW THAT WILL LEAD
TO THAT DECISION SEVERAL MONTHS
FROM NOW AND THAT QUESTION, I
THINK, REMAINS SOMEWHAT
MYSTERIOUS.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU AND I
APPRECIATE ALL OF THAT AND THAT
THE DOJ HAS TO TAKE ITS TIME TO
BUILD ITS CASE.
ALL DUE RESPECT TO MERRICK
GARLAND, THAT IS NOT TRUE.
DONALD TRUMP TODAY WHERE WE SIT
RIGHT NOW IS ABOVE THE LAW.
DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN CHARGED
WITH NOTHING.
ONE LEGAL WATCHDOG HAS SAID THAT
THERE ARE AT LEAST 48 POTENTIAL
CRIMES COMMITTED BY DONALD TRUMP
OVER THE COURSE OF HIS
PRESIDENCY OR WHILE HE WAS
CAMPAIGNING.
HE HAS NOT BEEN CHARGED FOR ANY
ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT,
USING THE GOVERNMENT TO PUNISH
HIS OPPONENTS, ANYTHING IN
CONNECTION WITH JANUARY 6,
MEDDLING IN ELECTIONS, AND,
LOOK, I WILL BE SUPER, SUPER,
HYPER, UBER FAIR, NOR HAS BILL
CLINTON.
HE IS NOT ALONE AS BEING A
POWERFUL MAN WHO HAS BEEN THUS
FAR ABOVE THE LAW.
I'M NOT A LEGAL ANALYST, NOR A
SCHOLAR OF THE LAW, I'M A NORMAL
PERSON AND I THINK IF YOU ARE A
NORMAL PERSON WITH, YOU KNOW,
SOME REASON YOU THINK, WELL,
DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN ABOVE THE
LAW, IT'S BEEN 18 MONTHS SINCE
THE INSURRECTION.
>> I MEAN, WHAT GARLAND WAS
ADDRESSING IS THIS IDEA THAT HAD
BEEN POINTING OUT THAT SOMEHOW
THE OPINION THAT A PRESIDENT IS
BEYOND PROSECUTION COULD BE
EXTENDED.
I KNOW IT'S UNSATISFYING FOR
PEOPLE BUT IT IS GOOD FOR
MERRICK GARLAND TO BE TAKING
EXTRA STEPS TO TRY TO
DEPOLITICIZE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AFTER POLITICIZATION.
THAT'S GOOD AND WHAT I THINK IS
NOT GOOD IS EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
LAW.
EVEN FOR EX-PRESIDENTS.
THIS IS AN UNPRECEDENTED
SITUATION AND I DO THINK THE
COMMITTEE HAS PROBABLY -- SEEMS
TO HAVE URGED ON AND CREATED
MORE URGENCY AROUND THE DOJ, BUT
HE WAS TRYING TO BE VERY CLEAR
YESTERDAY WITH REGARD TO AT
LEAST CRIMINAL LIABILITY FOR
TRYING TO OVERTURN AN ELECTION.
>> EVEN DONALD TRUMP KNOWS,
DONALD TRUMP IS TELLING PEOPLE
IN HIS INNER CIRCLE HE WANTS TO
RUN AGAIN BECAUSE HE KNOWS THE
PRESIDENCY WILL BE A SHIELD FROM
INDICTMENTS AND JAIL TIME.
>> WHAT HE'S THINKING IS THAT HE
CAN BRUSH BACK PITCH IF HE RUNS
AND SAY, LOOK, I'M ENGAGED IN
THE POLITICAL PROCESS AGAIN,
THEREFORE, ANY INDICTMENTS ARE
THEREFORE POLITICAL.
IN A NEW PIECE, MY NEXT GUEST
MAKES A CASE IN DEFENSE OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
BENJAMIN WITTES JOINS ME NOW.
BENJAMIN, WELCOME.
I'M GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
YOU'VE SEEN AND HEARD ALL THE
CRITICISM.
TOO SLOW.
PEOPLE PROBABLY ARE ADDING ON TO
THE MUELLER PROBE, I WOULD SAY,
IN THEIR LACK OF PATIENCE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON.
DO YOU THINK THAT THEY ARE
MOVING TOO SLOW, THAT THEY ARE
DRAGGING THEIR FEET WAITING FOR
THE COMMITTEE, AS SOME PEOPLE
BELIEVE?
>> I DON'T.
I THINK THEY HAVE MOVED ACTUALLY
REMARKABLY QUICKLY IN GENERAL.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE SCOPE AND
SCALE OF THE INVESTIGATION SINCE
JANUARY 6, 2021, WE'VE HAD MORE
THAN 850 INDICTMENTS.
A SURPRISING NUMBER OF THEM HAVE
BEEN OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ACCUSED
OF VERY VIOLENT, VERY BAD
OFFENSES.
THEY HAVE MOVED UP THE HIERARCHY
OF POTENTIAL DEFENDANTS
RELATIVELY QUICKLY.
THEY'VE MOVED UP TO SEDITIOUS
CONSPIRACY CASES, AND THEY ARE
NOW KNOCKING AT THE DOOR OF THE
POLITICAL ECHELON.
AND IF YOU'D SAID -- WE HAD BEEN
SITTING HERE JANUARY 7th, AND
YOU SAID, WHAT WOULD A
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATION LOOK
LIKE?
I WOULD DESCRIBE SOMETHING
EXACTLY LIKE THAT AS THE BEST
CASE SCENARIO FOR WHAT AN
INVESTIGATION MIGHT LOOK LIKE.
>> IT'S TRUE THEY'VE MOVED UP
THE HIERARCHY IN TERMS OF THE
CHARGES.
BUT THEY'VE BEEN CRITICIZED,
WHERE HE TALKS ABOUT THE
BOTTOM-UP APPROACH, RIGHT?
WE OFTEN HERE THE COLLOQUIAL
TERM ABOUT YOU GO AFTER THE BIG
FISH.
AND WHO'S THE BIG FISH?
IS THE APPROACH OF THE 800-PLUS
INDICTMENTS, THEY ARE PRETTY
LOW-LEVEL ACTORS, COMPARED TO,
OF COURSE, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IS THAT APPROACH FLAWED?
>> NO.
I DON'T THINK IT IS.
I -- LOOK.
I AGREE WITH ANDREW WEISSMAN
THAT IF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
IS NOT, TODAY, LOOKING AT THE
BROAD RANGE OF ACTIVITY THAT
DONALD TRUMP ENGAGED IN AND
OTHERS ENGAGED IN IN THE WAKE OF
THE ELECTION LEADING UP TO
JANUARY 6th, THAT WOULD LOOK
LIKE IT HAS A CERTAIN
INSTITUTIONAL BLINDERS ON.
BUT IN FACT WE KNOW THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS EXECUTED
SEARCH WARRANTS AGAINST JOHN
EASTMAN, ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
WAS HELPING THE PRESIDENT PLOT
THE FAKE ELECTORS.
>> THE EASTMAN MEMO.
>> THERE'S BEEN A SEARCH WARRANT
EXECUTED AGAINST EASTMAN.
THERE'S BEEN A SEARCH WARRANT
EXECUTED AGAINST JEFFREY CLARK,
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WHO TRUMP TRIED TO INSTALL AT
THE -- AS THE ACTING ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
>> BUT THESE WERE QUITE RECENT,
AND THEY WERE AFTER AT LEAST
TESTIMONY ABOUT EITHER IN THE
COMMITTEE.
>> SO, FIRST OF ALL, RECENT
ACTIVITY IS A SIGN THAT THE
INVESTIGATION IS ALIVE AND DOING
ITS WORK, RIGHT?
IF YOU SAID THERE'S BEEN NO
RECENT ACTIVITY, THAT'S WHAT
WOULD BOTHER ME.
MOREOVER, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, YOU KNOW, GETS THE
BENEFIT OF A LOT OF DIFFERENT
INPUTS, RIGHT?
IT GETS THE BENEFIT OF ALL THE
BOTTOMS-UP ACTIVITY THAT IT'S
ENGAGED IN.
AS THEY FLIP DEFENDANTS TH, THE
GET COOPERATION.
AS THEY BRING IN NEW DEFENDANTS,
THEY GET, YOU KNOW, NEW
ALLEGATIONS COME IN, RIGHT?
BUT THEY ALSO GET THE BENEFIT OF
JOURNALISM.
THERE'S A LOT OF JOURNALISM.
THEY GET THE BENEFIT OF THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE.
THE COMMITTEE'S CONDUCTED
1,000-PLUS INTERVIEWS.
SO, I DON'T THINK -- I THINK
IT'S A -- IT'S NOT A BUG.
IT'S A FEATURE THAT THE
INVESTIGATION APPEARS TO BE
ASSIMILATING INPUTS FROM ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
ONE IMPORTANT POINT ABOUT THIS,
THIS IS NOT LIKE WATERGATE WHERE
YOU HAVE A RELATIVELY DISCREET
FACT PATTERN, RIGHT?
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY TOTAL
DEFENDANTS THERE WERE IN
WATERGATE.
WATERGATE, BY THE WAY, TOOK FIVE
YEARS TO PROSECUTE THE WHOLE
THING.
THIS IS HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE SCATTERED
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
EVEN THE ACTIVITY THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS LOOKING AT -- IF
YOU THINK ABOUT IT
GEOGRAPHICALLY, IT INVOLVES
PEOPLE ALL OVER THE PLACE.
>> YEAH.
>> THIS IS GOING TO TAKE A
WHILE.
>> SPEAKING OF HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE, I WAS A LINE
CAREER PROSECUTOR.
EVERYONE KEEPS TALKING ABOUT
ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK GARLAND
WHO I KNOW YOU KNOW WELL.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT'S
THE CAREER PROSECUTORS WHO ARE
GOING TO BE BUILDING THESE CASES
AND PRESENTING IT TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN SOME FORM OR
FASHION.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
PERCEPTION, THOUGH, THAT PEOPLE
HAVE THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OR THE DOJ, MORE BROADLY, IS
PLAYING CATCH UP?
AND I ASK THIS SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE THERE WERE THESE LETTERS
TO THE COMMITTEE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WASN'T HANDING OVER
INFORMATION TO DOJ.
>> YEAH, SO, I -- SO, FIRST OF
ALL, IN A SITUATION IN WHICH THE
COMMITTEE IS DOGING A TOP-DOWN
INVESTIGATION, THE COMMITTEE
STARTS WITH THE QUESTION, WHAT
CAN WE SAY ABOUT POLITICAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND DONALD TRUMP?
THEY GET TO START WITH THE KING.
THEY INTERVIEW EVERYBODY AROUND
THE KING.
THEY INTERVIEW EVERYBODY --
THAT'S NOT THE WAY YOU CONDUCT A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION, AS YOU
KNOW.
AT THE CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION,
YOU DO IT MAYBE NOT FROM THE
VERY BOTTOM-UP, BUT YOU'RE GOING
TO START WITH THE PEOPLE BELOW.
IT IS NOT SURPRISING TO ME AT
ALL THAT THE COMMITTEE GETS TO
SOME PEOPLE STARTING AT THE TOP
BEFORE YOU GET THEM COMING UP
FROM THE BOTTOM.
TO ME, THE QUESTION IS THE
FOLLOWING: AS YOU LOOK AT THE
WAY THE INVESTIGATION
PROGRESSES, IS IT MOVING UP?
IS THERE PRESSURE FROM THE CASES
THEY ARE MAKING ON THE NEXT
WRUNG UP THE LADDER?
RIGHT NOW, IT SEEMS TO ME THERE
IS A LOT.
IT'S A VERY ACTIVE
INVESTIGATION, CROSSING LA LOT F
DIFFERENT TERRITORY, BOTH
LEGALLY AND FACTUALLY.
SO, AS LONG AS THAT'S THE CASE,
I'M NOT GOING TO SIT HERE AND
WORRY THAT THE SUBPOENA THAT
WENT OUT LAST WEEK DIDN'T GO OUT
LAST MONTH.